uh so i should say we have a we have a
uh really uh
you know a great panel uh that comes at
these questions from
from many different directions
so um
so let me let me introduce the panelists
as they are pinned up uh
so um
uh
so we have um
nathan nathan beep who is um
he uh he's from the university of
toronto and he he's worked on
many aspects of quantum algorithms for
the electronic structure problem for
quantum simulation hamiltonian
simulation
uh
scientific computing so uh
there's james whitfield who is one of
the pioneers in quantum algorithms uh
for electronic structure
uh starting his with his work in his phd
with alan
asparagus
uh lynlin is uh is uh is my colleague
from the math math department at uc
berkeley
and he has uh he has worked extensively
on classical electronic structure
simulations uh
with this
numerical analysis lens but
in the last few years he's gotten
increasingly interested in the quantum
quantum simulation aspects of this
problem
and
brigitte aveli who's again my colleague
in
in chemistry at uc berkeley uh brigitte
has been working in quantum computing
for a very long time uh
we co-direct the berkeley quantum uh
information and computing center she's
worked extensively on on quantum hair
correction the decorative subspaces
quantum control
she sits in the chemistry department
she's uh she's been thinking a lot about
both near-term
uh quantum algorithms for for quantum
chemistry as well as uh
as well as um
you know more scalable algorithms so
let's start with um
it would be good to hear from the from
the panelists about their reactions to
it to
to garnet's talk let me let me just say
um
before before you start um let me just
say uh speaking as a computer scientist
um you know first i really appreciate it
uh from garnett's uh talk you know from
your talk um
that it it provided a really accessible
window into into the methods uh you know
some of how
our chemists would look at these
problems
um
i
you know i i'd like to sort of throw out
a couple of uh
um
uh sort of issues or questions that
you know i'd i'd like to
if see if it can be addressed in this
panel so one of them has to do with the
fact that
well of course ground states are you
know computer scientists know and love
because uh you know it corresponds to
the kinds of questions we ask in
complexity theory
but um but
you know
is
when one's talking about chemistries are
excited states also of interest and if
so
is there a nice formulation you know so
for grant states there's a very nice
formulation for us to think about as
computer scientists you know which are
the interesting one you know
so it sort of says okay these are the
interesting questions what's the
complexity
but
you know but if they are really hard to
find then presumably even real
real systems don't find them you know if
they are computationally intractable and
so
how do you think about this and and is
there is there some
nice models so that we could start
thinking about them
and then the second question i had was
of a similar flavor with respect to
not not just
the statics but you know dynamics and so
so you know there we have this whole
notion of hamiltonian simulation
but again
my my
uh you know uh
my understanding and i think this is
what maybe steve flemier was referring
to is that
well
in in practice you're you're only
interested in
smaller parts of the of the puzzle and
the
the resources required to simulate the
entire system in full detail is would
probably be too much so again
you know is there a way that we can
simplify and think about these problems
from you know stepping back from a
computer science viewpoint but okay so
with with those you know i'd love to go
go to the panelists and
uh
hear your uh perspective and
about about the talk
i assume i'm gonna let the others talk
and i i will i could talk to enough yeah
but i mean at the end if i can give some
opinions okay great okay
um
so okay
unless somebody else wants to go first
oh i can i can start but
all right cool so again thanks a lot
thanks a lot garnet uh obviously you
know you know my point the point of view
is diametrically opposed to yours when
it comes to this but one thing i do want
to say is that you know despite despite
the fact that i disagree with many of
the fundamental conclusions
that are that are being made here one
thing that i think is vitally important
for everybody to get from this
is the fact that there are many many
examples in chemistry that are vastly
easier than what you would end up
believing from just taking a look at
doing naive fci in order to be able to
solve the particular problem
so you know i think that's a vital point
and also i think you know when looking
at benchmark examples of highly
correlated uh quantum systems you know
making sure that you're that you're
setting everything up to avoid you know
kind of like the danger zone of having
one-dimensional molecules that dmrg
might be really awesome at and things
like that but
i guess you know the part that i i think
that i i differ with garnet's
interpretation i think i agree with all
the numerix he always does a bang-up job
with all of that stuff it's undoubtedly
100 correct from my point of view
but one of the dangers that i think ends
up coming up with this actually goes
back to an older result from adiabatic
quantum computing
and so there was this early result that
was put out that uh by one of the
founders of adiabatic qc that ended up
claiming that uh basically uh threesat
could uh or case that more broadly can
be solved in polynomial time on quantum
computers by using um
a to the adiabatic algorithm and you
know basically what had happened is just
the examples that we're taking a look at
weren't drawn from a set that would end
up approaching a phase transition where
the typical problems ended up going from
easy to hard
and this i think ends up raising a
big and sort of deeper problem that ends
up coming up when both computer
scientists and chemists talk about both
of these things one of the things that
garnet is amazing at i think is like
what umich said is that you're one of
the garnet's one of the few people who
can kind of talk in the middle of these
two camps but one of the big challenges
that ends up coming up
is that
you can't really formally get the
asymptotic scaling of course from small
numerical examples
you never know whether or not you've
actually hit one of these transitions to
go into the hard instances
and on top of that you know you're not
ever really sure whether or not the
examples that you've taken for the
benchmark set that you take a look at
are representative of what the problem
is as a whole
and
finally i guess one of the things that i
think we you know in order to turn this
into i think more of a constructive uh
uh discussion about what the scalability
of the electronic structure problem
actually is
really having both sides agree upon what
the formal definition of the problem is
going to be you know is it in terms of
uh constant accuracy is accuracy a
variable that we can change you know how
are
how can the initial situation or sorry
how can the nuclear configurations be
contrived for it
these sorts of problems really these
things have to be addressed before i
think that we can actually get to a full
conclusion about it but again going back
to the the initial thing i think that
that's a vital point the other thing
that i kind of really want to make sure
that you know uh people recognize is
that well i'm not sure i buy garnet's
arguments about the um
accuracy of state preparation um this is
probably the biggest even for people who
believe in the exponential uh advantage
hypothesis for electronic structure the
question about the the overlap for state
preparation is totally unknown from a
rigorous perspective
and that's something that as a community
we need to think more clearly about no
matter what
but um yeah so that's that's kind of
like my initial thoughts about about
this
i i won't res i'm not going to respond
in detail because i feel that i i can
talk later but i just want to say nathan
i appreciate those comments and i think
they're very reasonable comments i don't
i don't disagree with them um although i
draw different conclusions exactly yeah
well uh since uh nathan is uh poses the
kind of like idea of the paper i don't
know the perspective of jameson brigitte
on this so i feel that as a co-author of
the paper i should say some something a
lot more different
just to balance it out so
yeah i mean i mean the third quarter i
indeed agree with garnett on at least
the most of the points but uh while
nathan said that garnet
come from the quantum chemistry
community and can really talk to like
both quantum chemistry and the other
computer science i guess i'm also like
like in the middle but in a different
sense in the sense that i'm in the
middle of nowhere but uh
but
but uh
there's some there's some actually some
advantage
by being in the middle of nowhere so i
can at least see my say my perspective
of like both communities
so
i think one of the
outcomes of this research that
done by a lot of this numerics very
carefully carried out by garner's group
is that it undoubtedly raises the
question as nathan said earlier how we
should actually think about this kind of
initial state preparation problem or we
actually do some resource estimates is
that really reasonable to really assume
the overlap is equal to
one and then we do some quantum phase
estimation and that's it right it means
there are some papers
along this flavor i can come back to
resource estimation later
but
from my perspective the classical
heuristics there are numerous of those i
mean it's very very hard to pin down the
asymptotic complexity of even much
simpler quantum algorithms not to
mention like uh sorry not much simpler
classical algorithms not to mention the
very complex ones let's say that's the
matrix in blending theory uh but on the
quantum side at least based on the tools
we have right now the situation is
actually somewhat simpler there is of
course there's this vqe part which is uh
hard to analyze analytically and
theoretically but it's going to be
invaluable uh for initial state
preparation right because uh generically
preparing good initial state is hard
but once you
have a sort of like a good initial state
then you don't have that many options
really there's a qpe and there's a post
qpe and they differ in terms of some
skating with respect to precision uh
with respect to the initial overlap but
the basic idea are actually the same
it's basically some sort of filter and
filter out unwanted things and
leave the things you have and that's uh
and make sure
you analyze the errors
things don't blow up
uh there's not much pollution so on so
forth and then you're done so the
mechanism is not that complicated and
there have been a lot of progresses in
the past
few years on this and hopefully there's
something from our group will come out
tonight and uh
along this line and uh especially
targeting the early fall tolerance
setting
but
i would say that all the mechanisms they
are similar they're
understandable ish and the there's some
performance guarantee
then there's this big question which is
how do you really go to the uh
initial overlap uh like that is let's
say you don't need to go to initial
overlap equal to one but the initial lab
overlap that's omega one let's say 0.01
then they're roughly speaking there are
two approaches one can do one is to just
do harder uh like
work harder on the
heuristics
could be vqe could be some other things
and so garnet showed that sometimes or
at the backstage preparation
it's not good enough to just work like
on the with a pencil on paper sometimes
it's really
insightful to just carry out some of the
simulations i think some more work along
this line should be done for hard
chemistry problems required a lot of
talking of the two communities but there
is another one that was raised earlier
which is also very timely and very very
important which is generically
um
all the could be post-qp algorithms they
will fail if the initial overlap is bad
i think nathan gives example of flipping
the coins to see the chat and indeed
that's uh i mean the difficulty of this
thing
but
maybe at least for some initial state or
for some quantum algorithms you can they
can work somehow in some regimes when
the gamma is accurate
the overlap is small that's possible and
that's vastly understudied in the
literature i think that's a really a
timely and important question that's
what i think
so i i think i follow up on that i think
um i'm really looking forward to reading
the paper i think this was a fantastic
talk a lot of things that i thought and
i think it's really nice to see numerix
behind it
um this idea of qma versus bqp
is really i think at the heart of the
story and you said at the end of the
last slide that this is not about
excited states i think excited states
exactly we get to bqp
and i've had a feeling for a long time
as the bqe literature started to expand
that these are all trying to solve a qma
heart problem that there may be no
actual way to do so
in the instances that are hard for both
quantum and hard classically and i think
garnett's at least what he's shown goes
to show some evidence to that to that
argument and so i thought that was
really impressive
i also think that it's one of the things
you outlined inside of your talk i
thought was quite interesting and it was
very
very much a passing moment where you
mentioned that um you know going from a
model system to the avonitio system
doesn't change the complexity much but i
think there's an aspect of that you can
also read as
these are the things we know how to do
we've learned how to do them by going
through the toy model figuring out
what's not important what we can throw
away what approximations to make to get
to that initial model with the right
techniques the right methods and i think
that's really what's driven a large part
of what quantum chemistry has become and
what it can do is just on the fact of
what we're trying to do and it's almost
like machine learning in the sense that
it's trained to do this and so i think
having quantum computers go after the
things that quantum chemistry is trained
to do
is not a formula for success and i think
this is where i i really think that
you've kind of laid out arguments to
that point
i also think there's one other thing to
to point out what nathan said about
pinning down the question of quantum
chemistry i think when i hear computer
scientists approach this idea of quantum
chemistry there's often these arguments
about scaling and how the system goes as
you go to very large system sizes but
when we think of quantum chemistry quite
often we don't go to large system sizes
and it's not really a sensible thing to
talk of a super large you know
biomolecule you wouldn't use electronic
structure to approach that you start
dealing with thermodynamics vibrations
and other things entering that i think
that there's some limit to what the
scaling even makes sense to talk about
for electronic structure problem before
you start talking about something
entirely different and so i think how
does it actually play with the theory of
complexity something that i think is is
kind of very much open to see how that
actually plays out
i would be interested to hear a little
bit about how
in the beginning you talked about this l
being the the parameter talking of
scaling and quite often when you go to
um
to translation in variant systems it's
the scaling with the number of k points
that really determines complexity and so
thinking about how that might actually
interact with some of these arguments
whether it's just the same argument or
whether it changes because you haven't
changed the number of atoms just change
the number of k points that you need to
integrate over
so yeah like i said i'm looking forward
to reading the paper and hearing what uh
what everyone else has to say
hey i should say something now so
going up great talks thanks very much
it's very stimulating and also a very
very complete sort of summary of the
state of play right now i think with
regard to the ground states
so
one comment which
i think
really pulled for me for my own interest
i pulled out of your uh your
presentation was the same and you've
made that
well we want to put in more structure to
get good initial states
but if we do that we the danger is that
we might be finding better way by
finding better under making better on
that state for the quantum calculations
we might be um
shooting ourselves in the foot in terms
of advantage because we're finding out
how to make better heuristics also for
the classical method
but i think this is actually a place
where effort should be
focused basically on taking as much
structure as possible from classical
quantum chemistry
to the quantum algorithms
but still to find to identify the places
where classical techniques still cannot
solve these
and so the way i i'm looking at
electronic structure these days is more
i know you're focused on ground states
but i'm looking at it more in terms of
ground and excited states together
looking at methods that can solve for
both and in particular focusing on
strong correlation problems
and i notice you didn't really say much
about
multi-reference states
or even multi-determinant states which
seems like a natural thing to use for
better undoubtedly just to start with
right now even from a given reference
but when you're looking at strong
correlation systems without doing
tensor networks and so on but in
practice so one often uses
multi-reference heart report states
where you have states which are
non-orthogonal
and if you start dealing with
non-orthogonal methods there there is
you can clearly identify places where in
principle there's an exponential
advantage
because if you start to make
overlaps
with
couple cluster
techniques without with different with
non-orthogonal reference states then you
you can't actually truncate very easily
and in principle
the coupled cluster
expansion continues forever and then you
do have an exponential problem
and that's a problem so we're actually
looking at that right now we have
writing a paper on it coming out soon
probably hopefully soon
but uh it does seem that that's a
problem where at least on paper
there is something which is
uh
i'm not sure how generic it is but
when you when you're dealing with these
uh ground states and low-lying excited
states together
of these metal complexes and so on as a
generic problem there i think there is
there is room there for
other techniques distinct from the
method that you mentioned
on the classical side which which would
be interesting to do but cannot be done
can only be done in a very approximate
way right now
but we would scale exponentially even
for small systems they would scale
exponentially in the basis
size
so that that's that's one thing um
and then
also yes i was also going to put in a
plea for i think excited states are
just as important as ground states in
terms of chemical reactions all the
photo activated
reactions in biological systems all
proceed on excited state surfaces
after all there's just more of them yeah
so i think it's it's it's it's good to
uh stimulate algorithms not just for the
ground state
and uh as james says you know maybe
there is a better more of an advantage
there
but even also
they'll also make a comment about the
accuracy so quantum chemists really like
to nail this
accuracy of the energy the ground state
energy to within this 1.6 milli artery
chemical accuracy
um that sometimes you have a system
that's so complicated that you aren't so
much in
interested in knowing say the sequence
of states the ground state and the first
few excited states you you aren't
your first question isn't necessarily
exactly what energy they are but it
might be what's the ordering of the spin
states
what is the spin if you have high spin
complexes and they
like like the oxygen evolving complex
the manganese happens in the oxygen
involving complex that's a very complex
spin chain of reactions electronic
reactions going through different spin
oxidation states or oxidation states of
manganese corresponding to different
spin states
and there you were really interested in
knowing the ordering first of all before
you want to actually nail down the
energies
so i think there's all the other other
targets that one could go for
interestingly that that's actually kind
of a decision problem like the kind that
ike was talking about actually yeah it's
multiple it's not it's not a binary
decision problem but it could be
formulated as
um a decision problem that's yeah that's
a good connection
yeah
so and so maybe garnet i would be
interested to hear if you could say
something about your perspective on
excited states and whether you think the
same
same kind of conclusions about eqa would
hold as well or whether it's a
completely different ballgame in the
excited states
uh sure sure i mean okay so
i mean many many points have been raised
um and so
uh i don't think
and
let's see so
i'm trying to think maybe there's some
generic comment i can make that
addresses a lot of points which is that
and then i mean then i try and address
the excited state question very like
very specifically but
um the generic comment is um
this is relates to what maybe nathan's
original points um
you know
uh
it's it's so nathan in the beginning
asked the question in some sense
you know how do i know that
if i don't look at look a bit more
carefully or look more deeply and this
is also related to sergio's point you
know you'll see something else you know
you didn't currently we may not be in
the asymptotic regime i may not have
looked at quite the right problems these
problems might have been centered and
those are all fair points because one's
doing a finite amount of calculations
and final amount of data
but they're very important because
asymptotics can be very different right
it's a bit like the riemann hypothesis
it doesn't matter if you compute lots of
zeros
it's not really you don't really know
the answer to the question
but i i would just say that it
you know ever you know evidence
this hypothesis is
the the point of view on proposing is
actually very easy to disprove because
if you can find
evidence
on the other side
that's already that's that's sufficient
there's qma hard results that we have
out right now oh no yeah yeah but i've
sort of excluded
you know
well okay i mean there's um
i don't know what you're referring to i
mean you went well what i'm talking
about is like the generalized electronic
structure problem right
is uh i'm not talking about any
particular molecule if we knew a
particular molecule that would be
fantastic yeah yeah yeah but the formal
problem that
encompasses what we talk about when we
talk about quantum chemistry has qma
hard instances right right right and so
then what that is to construct an
explicit
abstract construction right i mean it's
okay
about the qma constructions for
electronic structure you really don't
have that much information inside
electronic structure hamiltonian to
actually manipulate you only have the
scalar potential so it's not actually
that easy to say that the qma hard but
formally one can write a
a circuit to you know hamiltonian
construction right for the qma so one
can construct it but but um okay so that
just so all i'm saying is it would be
very good
it's if one takes the very skeptical
view of my
of the conclusions of my talk anyone can
be skeptical about any aspect but of the
curve
conclusions then i think the most
productive thing is to
is to con construct some evidence on
that numerical evidence for the other
you know and then when we change one's
mind but numerical evidence won't settle
this the skeptics we need theoretical
evidence so how do we go forward and
actually develop because we've got
theoretical evidence on the hardness
side it's just a question of
extrapolating out to the urine the cases
you studied numerically
how is it
how can we kind of you know get
theoretical evidence that we can you
know extrapolate and maybe say that
these cases that we suspect to be hard
are in some sense isolated or not
typical of the ensemble that we really
actually care about in the chemistry
case and i don't know how to do that so
so also let me address one other mention
another point because there's a common
misconception like when people have
listened to my talk and then trying to
like compress in their head to one point
that in the end my talk is just about
saying something related to the fact
that ground state is formerly in qma but
actually that's really not the way the
talk
that's actually really not what it talks
about the talk is really
about
um
actually perhaps most of chemistry is
not
not in qma
right i'm excluding from the very
beginning the kind of problems are in
qma but then for those instances perhaps
that they also happen to be
you know classically easy right so it's
really talking about the easier type
problems rather than the really hard
problems and and that's that set is very
hard to characterize that's the
theoretical problem yeah and this is the
big big challenge right is that i don't
know how to characterize what we mean by
typical molecules
[Music]
so i think it's interesting there's two
things there right so i think nathan
your question is about typical and i
think garnett's talking not so much
about typically what i understood is
talking about what conditions make it
easy to solve electronic structure
and you know is that satisfied or not so
it's asking about the characterization
that makes it not quite hard anymore
then you can make some solutions some
progress towards that and i think that's
a really interesting question about
ground states because it's really when
the heuristics work you could ask a lot
of questions about heuristics but at the
end of the day i mean if you take the
generic ground state problem then it's
qma hard if you take some very very
restricted one then perhaps as garnett's
pointing out maybe if it's easy to solve
classically
or you overseas it's all quantum
mechanically it's easy to solve
classically and it's hard to find the
bit that's like
easy quantumly and hard classically
right another thing evidence for that
that's also really important to take a
look at is that you know if we take a
look at say uh
um
np-complete problems like you know for
example maxsat
if you take a look at that there's
different approximation ratios within
which
very naive and efficient classical
algorithms will be capable of producing
the the
solution within
desired accuracy
and so the question i guess you know
about chemistry right is that you know
what's the is there some something
equivalent that maybe where maybe your
these results are stumbling on that the
formal problem is actually hard it's
just there's the we don't know what the
kind of approximation ratio is before we
start and
you know the accuracy is so high that
the the the typical instances are hard
um
so if if i have to
interject here so
just um
from a from a pure you know complexity
viewpoint as you said okay so there are
the qma heart problems
which for which um
even quantum won't solve them
then you say the other there are
there are the problems that you can
currently say well maybe these couple of
quantum heuristics would solve and and
maybe there's you're saying well
i don't see any examples where classical
algorithms wouldn't solve them
but then
but then you can approach the problem
from a different viewpoint and you can
say look
there are still a number of quantum you
know chemistry problems like electronic
structure problems that
that you don't know how to solve
classically but nature knows how to
solve them
because it's obviously finding that
electronic structure whether it be a
ground state or maybe not getting to a
ground state but something else
and so
so in principle we we think that
that should be you know if you if you
simulate the dynamics you should be able
to get to that structure so so now we
could we could sort of say well there
are similar problems classically for
instance protein folding etc where we
said look
it can be done therefore it can be you
know
you know since nature solves it there
must be a way to do it do it on a
computer and in fact alpha fold
sort of does it right it's a big one of
the big successes of deep maths
so so one could one could sort of say
well look
why shouldn't there be a classical
algorithm then you know if nature does
it and and of course it could be the
case that when nature does it it's going
through some states which are
enormously entangled and we won't even
have any uh you know any reasonable
onsets to represent those intermediate
intermediate states
and that might be a reason why there
should be a quantum algorithm but not a
classical algorithm for uh for finding
these so what you know how would you
think about
is is that does that you know so this is
of course
naively thinking as a computer scientist
but what what what would you say uh to
that i i i i believe umesh
i think you're addressing me is that
correct
yes yes yes
okay so i i would just say i mean i
think the first part of what you're
saying is asking about the relevance of
qma because
i mean qma is not so relevant in the
physical in some sense because of
something find some state that
presumably found it in a reasonable
amount of time right it's executing
dynamics that is bqp not qma
i think that's
maybe what i was saying was no i was i
was sort of acknowledging your point
that the q and a complete you know qma
complete problems are not going to be
the place where you find quantum
advantage because right right because
even quantum algorithms are going to
have trouble with them yeah so
yes yeah so so there so the question is
then what what to do the remaining set
um and so i mean i think the real
achilles heel of rigorous quantum
algorithms is the fact that locality is
so prevalent
in the lower energy states
right and so
i think for core migrants to have an
advantage you do need to rely on these
states which have some
really global entanglement structure and
as the system size gets bigger
you know you retain this global
entitlement structure more and more you
know just keeps keeps going out
and
and then at least from daily experience
in the kind of bread and butter type of
chemistry that molecules that one thinks
about
you know this
that tends to be you know our experience
is that things have after some point
behave independently of some other point
of some other region and that
that sort of
kind of
is it makes it that is so common that it
makes it a little bit hard for me
personally to see why one should always
have some dependence on some global
information out to infinite scale i mean
this is some scale after which a table
is a table separate from the chair you
know so
um
so but of course it could be some scale
that's really large and and in all if
all intents and purposes you know if the
quality doesn't manifest fast enough
that
that it saves you
computationally and you but
um but yeah i mean i think that's
why it's not that easy to find uh
exponential coordinate advantage now in
in the case of dynamics
and so brigitte just very quickly you
also like sizes and why think about it i
mean i think
many statements about ground states you
know the low-lying excited states are
not so not so different that's my my
view but
but highly very highly excited states
can be very different and
um so i'd say that
i don't think the first excited state
necessarily
you know i don't think there should be
another paper in the first excited state
you know writing a paper in the ground
state um but i don't think it's gonna be
significantly different when you go to
the first excited state in practice but
highly excited states though can be very
i think can be com computation very
different well what about um let me
bring up clinical intersections
what about i mean yeah so the really
tough problems where you have to then
have an intersection of potential
surfaces and you know breakdown of non
or open approximation i
yeah there are many problems that are
very difficult and are current and
though they they're currently in
tractable because they're too many
degrees of freedom and so and so
but i
yeah i mean i
i suspect that at least at low energies
you still
don't have uh
the sort of polynomial exponential kind
of divide you know isn't change too much
at low energies whereas you have to
perhaps go to high energies to
um
uh that chaotic type things where you
where you get this uh
uh really sort of exponential stuff
uh reappearing there aren't really any
good
uh classical methods for dealing with
chronic dynamics like chronic
intersections i agree yeah i mean
anything coupling electron nuclei
quantumly
we currently don't have
good methods and perhaps we net it will
never be practical
but it might
i guess my point is it may it may be a
polynomial problem rather than uh even
it can still be very impractical as a
polynomial
so can i ask one question i think in in
a large part of the arguments both you
and lynn kind of set out with was about
adiabatic state preparation state
preparation more broadly
so is it possible that to get a quantum
speed up or to even get exponential
quantum advantage you might need to
avoid preparing a state
to just take a random state and somehow
use information about the hamiltonian or
something so well
i mean
so
very very roughly i may say you can
you know it
you might be able to you know do
something locally right and then you
know and then in that sense bypass a
global overlap and
um like if you had completely isolated
systems you would determine the ground
state by determining the ground state
one at a time right
so
you know that type of heuristic
could be could be imagined but
maybe lynn had a different perspective
no i actually agreed that uh
very much
in line with what i said earlier that
this kind of theoretical studies of
different strategies that can somehow
let you bypass this
constraint by the overlap global overlap
would be very valuable and seems to be
underexplored and i also want to
say something my personal perspective
which is uh again from the perspective
in the middle of nowhere
that i mean a lot of the discussions so
far about the
power of theoretical studies and if you
really dive a little bit deeper you find
that this is specific about the power of
complexity theory theoretical studies
to me to a person like me
while i appreciate that there have been
numerous developments in complexity
theories address very challenging
problems
i somehow always feel that complexity
theory is just too big of a gun or it's
like a two-coat grain
to really analyze some of the effects we
just mentioned earlier that's the
conical intersection it's like using a
tweezer with diameter with like
10 meters to pick up a bow or something
like that i mean it's possible but it's
just a feel awkward
uh and
many of these systems iron software
clusters or uh right and nitrogenized
things that are quite specific and
the the effects are pretty delicate to
me uh
while theoretical studies they're very
useful
but
what may be equally useful or
maybe let's say equally useful
is a more careful resource estimate and
if there's a quantum computer walk
around it i'll be thrilled just to
run in there but before that we do our
best to take into account both the
best heuristics and just estimate the
cost right in a reasonable way and to
balance out the cost of the initial
state of preparation and the post
initial state preparation steps it's not
like the initial state preparation has
to prepare a state with the fidelity one
that just sounds yeah that's too hard uh
to too high a task for uh for heuristics
and then
merit is caused with
that of the best classical algorithm
because as garner said there is this
numerator divided by denominator problem
we can maybe do some theory on the
numerator side which is the quantum the
denominator is just nasty nobody in the
classical world even worry about these
problems right so this will never be
settled if nobody is working on this
cloud the complexity of those classical
heuristics i think the best way should
be heuristic versus heuristics so
that's it
maybe i'm too pessimistic in terms of
the power of theory uh there definitely
have been a lot of progresses in the
past few years but i really think in the
end should be heuristics versus
heuristics
but i guess the real challenges is that
we don't have a fault tolerant quantum
computer
and because we don't have that we can't
really test the quantum heuristics at
the scales that we would like uh in
order to you know because ideally once
we have that right then the ultimate
point of comparison will be dollars to
solution
yeah
i i'll just say i i've heard that
argument before nathan many times and
it's to some extent true and i'm waiting
for my friends to build me a com
computer
but
but i do think that you can people can
test them much more than they currently
do
also yeah
i just want a second i just want a
second garnet point like for example
many of the studies here right and you
do some n by two and by four type of
simulations why you can do that well
that's the best you can do with the dmrp
techniques but doesn't mean that you
learn nothing from those calculations i
definitely agree that you can do more
and just say
try best to have more concrete numbers
numbers versus numbers instead of
complexity versus complexity that
doesn't address the problem of conical
intersection well i think one other
thing that would be really interesting
to add just to to follow up on linlin's
point is that um
we think about uh the theoretical
methods of computer science quite often
it's the worst case scenario and i think
getting it what nathan's asking you know
how do we know that this doesn't work or
how do we know about chemistry can we
get an actual ensemble upon which to do
average case complexity to actually talk
about you know maybe statistical
properties of an average molecule nathan
had a paper many years ago where they
tried parameterizing some ensemble
molecules and i think it was very poorly
yeah well you know at least it's an idea
but i think it's worth going back to to
see can we characterize things
theoretically better by having some
something to average over i think this
might be an interesting way to kind of
address linlin's point about things
being too too heavy-handed instead of
complexity
i think you know but but one thing
though that is definitely a good way
that i think we should be using
complexity is that you know we should be
really skeptical of any result that ends
up um
contradicting well-motivated complexity
theoretic conjectures
you know like if we ever see anything
that suggests you know
p is equal to qma uh specifically that's
a big red flag that is you know if true
we should all go out and share the
million dollar prize for this because
i'm i and i'm down to split it evenly if
you guys are
but the the the thing is is that we
should use that aspect of it but of
course we should also you know yeah i
agree completely with the other side
right just because of the fact that you
know there exists uh worst case
scenarios that are computationally
suspected to be difficult that doesn't
mean either that the typica the typical
ones are computationally difficult and
it also doesn't mean that your
particular problem whether typical or
not is computationally difficult so i
think yeah developing better ensembles
is a great way of going about it
and to if we want both sides to meet in
the middle the second thing is
getting a firm agreement upon what the
computational problem exactly is uh you
know and asking okay well are we giving
ourselves
access to the ground state you know are
we not giving ourselves access to the
ground state how you know
being able to pose something that's a
well-defined problem that both sides
agree on
and then i think the the next point that
really is is needed in order to get an
understanding
about this
is to um
really actually kind of i think
nail down we really want to nail down
once we have those things what the
computational phase diagram kind of ends
up looking like
you know as we decrease epsilon my
strong strongly held belief is is that
as we shrink our air tolerance smaller
and smaller and smaller
that will hit a regime where the we'll
see the computational overhead blow up
for many of the
methods that are efficient at fixed
precision
and i'd like to get an idea once we've
got an agreement upon you know
what the problem is
how that ends up looking like and then
if we can give some numerical evidence
about that then i think that might be
helpful but better yet
asking are there simplified versions
perhaps that aren't electronic structure
that maybe are a little bit easier that
we could actually get more
a concrete understanding about and have
some rigorous theoretical scaling
arguments on the other side and maybe we
can somehow sandwich the problem of how
hard real chemistry is
in between the extreme examples and on
either side
okay great well
nathan you may well have the last word
here so
um
let's see uh garnet that was a there was
a really fantastic uh very clear and
very thought-provoking talk and
[Music]
you know brigitte
james lynn and nathan that was really
really good insights into
know into into these issues and
and also to the to the audience for
fantastic questions in the in the
beginning
um
so next week we have a we have a
colloquium by uh
by mark zandry on the
on verifiable quantum advantage without
structure
so um
so look forward to seeing you then
thanks a lot
thank you everyone
thanks
thanks bye
you